make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into Shazam
yes we are getting back into Shazam it's
been a long time since we covered this
and the only reason why we're even
covering it now is because what's
getting ready to go on Shazam is about
to get really awesome
yeah no spoilers but what we do here is
we basically pick up with Billy Batson
and Mary Marvel now of course they're
escaping the fun lands and for those of
you guys who are playing catch-up right
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar one I invite you to watch the
other videos that we have down in the
description those will get you caught up
on everything going on with Shazam but
the long and short of this is that the
Shazam comic really kind of picks up
directly after Justice League right and
I don't really mean Justice League
insofar as what's going on with Snyder
and perpetuo and all that kind of stuff
I mean Justice League insofar as when
the new 52 first launched Shazam did not
get his own solo book instead he was
basically a backup feature in in the the
Justice League comics you got issue
number zero which basically gave us his
origin and then you got issues one
through 12 I think in justice Lee they
covered the stories and then it got
dropped off and that was basically it
and then what this did this particular
line of comics as part of DC rebirth or
the DC Universe line whatever you want
to call it essentially just picks up
directly after that right now we can
kind of assume that Shazam has been
doing things in between but the story's
really self-contained
and there's no real reference to
anything else that's been going on
outside of what we saw in the Justice
League backup features and this right so
you can kind of read it in isolation
which is actually a pretty good thing
it's not really a bad thing but what
ended up happening is Billy Batson had
never really gotten an answer from the
wizard Shazam why he was chosen to be
Shazam different things like that
because as you guys know from the origin
that basically the wizard Hedison Tom
Emma Gorgon or whatever his name is had
basically died when he gave Billy the
power of Shazam and so he never really
got any answers after that and so the
idea was to gather the Shazam family
together and then go into the mad or go
into the rock of eternity and asked the
wizard but when they got there there was
nobody there the whole place is
basically empty and they discovered this
giant wall that had this map of the
magic lands and they entered into the
fun lands which is of course where they
are right now but what end up happening
is when they into the fun lands it
seemed like the greatest place ever but
when they turned into the Shazam family
the fun land realized they were adults
right in adults are basically made to
work as slaves to power the fun lands
and so essentially everybody except for
Billy and Mary for either cast out or
somehow managed to escape and ended up
back in there or ended up in the
different lands that are out there right
so this is basically Mary and Billy
trying to get out and then
jumping into the wildlands now this also
picks up with the Black Adam and in dr.
sivana fight because that was kind of a
cliffhanger that we kind of left off on
in the last video is that basically
Black Adam showed up after having been
freed accidentally by Savannah and then
basically kind of going on a warpath and
trying to stop sivanna
right because Savannah's possessed by
mr. mind which is those of you guys know
is that small little worm
they basically controls the minds of
other people and it is also insanely
powerful depending on how much energy he
consumes but the idea here is that
Savannah and mr. mind desire to enter
into the magic lands and then basically
steal all that power in the magic land
itself and because black items been
around for so long he understands the
magic lands he knows what they're about
and knows the power that can be held
within there but also knows the danger
that the magic lands pose and really
kind of gets into a conflict with mr.
mind you know and and Savannah basically
saying you don't know what it is that
you're doing but you have no clue what
it is that you're doing here and so as a
results that with their conflict kind of
going away that it does there's this
massive explosion and then Billie and
Mary are essentially thrust out of the
portal to the to the wild lands and back
into the real world now this kind of
picks up with the other plot point that
was going on which is basically the
father of Billy Batson returning and it
wasn't you know up until this point it
was kind of just a background theme
right it was just kind of a theme that
was there it was Billy Batson's dad's
return is it actually his dad you know
what's really going on that was the kind
of questions that we were left asking
here and so as a result of that you know
Billy basically rushes down stairs
alongside Mary and then you know you
have Victor and you have you have Rosa
their adoptive parents who basically say
like Billy Batson there's a man here to
see you and Billy realizes that and
looks deadest basically his dad and so
the two of them have this really really
heartfelt conversation and it's really
emotional and this is one of the great
things about Geoff Johns writing he's
exceedingly good at this at taking
situations and and really kind of
drawing out the emotional element of
them but what ends up happening is
basically you kind of get this partial
explanation in so far that Billy Batson
was basically born in zambrano Minnesota
and Billy's grandfather didn't like his
dad and so the initial idea was that his
grandfather was going to try to separate
Billy's mom and Billy from Billy's dad
and so as a result of that Billy's
mother and father basically absconded
right they kind of took off and they
ended up going to Philadelphia after
Billy was born and then just kind of
made a life on their own the issue with
this is that things more or less kind of
went belly-up now this is where things
get a little bit murky because if you go
and you read the new 52 origin from
Justice League number zero it's
basically the idea the Billy Batson z--
parent
9 what this does is it throws in the
notion that Billy Batson's dad did not
die but he's actually been in prison all
this time more so than that if there was
in the idea that his mother's still
alive but seems to be living back in
Minnesota again so it's not as though
his parents had been completely removed
from the picture at least you know his
parents have died is that his parents
just aren't in this life anymore but we
don't really know what happened that's
kind of the explanation is sort of left
hanging here and as one of these things
where Jeff John sets up the plot point
right because what he basically tells
Billy or at least the father of Billy
what he basically tells the son is I
want you to go with me and I want you to
help me find your mom and so from there
you end up jumping directly into Eugene
and Pedro while they're in the game land
and the game lands is one of these
places worse almost like ready player
one but the difference here is that
instead of it being this sort of oasis
where you can kind of go out and do your
thing and you can just kind of hang out
be whatever you want to be and just sort
of live your life in this gigantic
digital space in the game lands you're
gaming all the time right like
everything that you can do in this game
is based on how many points you have if
your point count is too low you cannot
even do something as simple as start a
car right so it's all based on the
points you have right so it's kind of a
blend between that episode from from
Black Mirror where it's all based on how
many social media points you have and
like ready player one it's kind of a
combination of those two things but with
Eugene and Pedro basically trying to
find a way to make their escape there's
suddenly met by the arrival of the
wizard Shazam and this is very
intriguing here because the wizard
should not be alive so the question is
why is he here now understand this is
one thing to bear in mind
Eugene Pedro everybody in the Shazam
family except for Billy Batson do not
know who the wizard is they've never met
him they don't know any of that stuff
and even we as the reader are pretty
ambiguous to the pass of the wizard
Shazam how did it like the rock of
eternity and the god pantheon come into
existence where did all that come from
and so from there you really kind of
jump to one of the cooler moments in the
story when Mary starts talking to her to
her parents Victor and and Rosa and the
kind of asking questions like where is
everybody and what in the heck is going
on here you know and so ultimately Mary
does the only thing she feels like she
can do which is reveal herself she
shouts the word Shazam and basically
says we're all superheroes all of us
kids are superheroes and this is a this
is a badass moment like it's pretty cool
right it's one of the coolest moments
coming out of the story because it's
like okay so like basically as she
reveals herself to them and it's kind of
one of the things that we'd always sort
of known but one of the things that that
really went on here is that Billie did
not want to tell his parents about all
this Mary's response was we to tell them
because there are
they love us they deserve to know
Billy's response was they don't need to
know we'll take care of this on our own
they don't really need to know
everything about this and so from there
what you end up doing is basically
jumping directly into the water lands
and the Oise endure lands are really
kind of cool insofar as it's a
hodgepodge and kind of an amalgamation
of Alice in Wonderland and The Wizard of
Oz where I kind of combined it into one
now the reality and this is something
that will you know someone's kind of
explained later but we'll cover it here
the reality of this is that when the war
of the magic lands previously broke out
right what you ended up getting was
basically Dorothy Dorothy from from The
Wizard of Oz and Alice from Alice in
Wonderland combining their two worlds
together in order to combine their
forces and then stave off attacks from
the other other Wizarding lands right so
you know that's really why this this
territory kind of exists here but what
you end up getting is that where the
White Rabbit is being attacked by the
monkeys of the Wicked Witch of the West
I think it was do you suddenly met by
the arrival of the wizard Shazam along
with Eugene and Pedro and so it's kind
of like okay so like this is cool
because basically they're they're
essentially marshalling forces right
they're bringing forces back together
and so with that being the case
Billy basically goes back into the house
talking to his parents realizing that
Mary's already revealed her identity to
them and then in turn he's like okay if
we're putting our cards on the table
let's put him on the table so he
basically shouts Shazam and then his dad
starts to freak out he's like dude we're
all like all of our kids are superheroes
this is ridiculously awesome and so what
we do is we kind of get this interesting
sort of little fast-track on these these
situations that are going down right in
the sense that uh Darla and Freddy
Freeman are basically being held captive
in the wild lands because at you know
for those guys who don't remember the
wild lands was a territory that was
originally ruled by humans but
ultimately the animals rose up against
humans and then overthrew them the
difference is that the Tigers allied
themselves with humans as part of the
conflict and that's why Tigers are
considered outcasts and the wild lands
and any humans that have found our force
are really fed to Tigers who are treated
very much like animals right in a sense
that the other animals in the wild lands
have basically become the humans but the
Tigers are treated in kind of a
demeaning way and so what you end up
getting is one of the Tigers tawny
jumping in and then saving Darla and
Freddy Freeman now I'm tawny and here's
the thing for people who are reading the
comic right now they'll be like yeah man
tawny is amazing do I love tawny do I
love I love like like talked to tawny
do this like it he's amazing I'm pretty
sure it's a dude but like it's it's it's
cool like he's he's one of the cooler
characters but basically he saves Darla
and Freddy and then essentially like
when they try
to make their escape they end up
crashing down into the dark lands and
the exact same thing goes on with Billy
Batson Billy Batson trying to make his
way and basically save the rest of the
Shazam family after spilling the beans
to his parents ends up in the dark lands
as well and so what is it happening here
is you end up having him kind of making
his way through there and in this area
that's really sort of murky right and in
pretty creepy
you know in terms of it being like a
series of cemeteries and and so on and
so forth but then you suddenly met by
the arrival of a ghost right who's
bearing the Shazam crust and that's kind
of the cool thing about it because as he
talks to this ghost this ghost is like
well we here as part of our family
basically Sheppard the living who
stumble across this realm back to the
world they're supposed to be in right
back to the place are supposed to be if
for some reason they fall through here
and this is important because one of the
things that this really establishes is
that Billy Batson and the Shazam family
we're essentially the only ones who
didn't know about the wildlands right
those individuals who were part of the
other realms of the wildlands were aware
of the other realms and the wildlands
right so the people in the and the
wildlands were I guess really the magic
lands with people in the wildlands are
aware of the people in the dark dark
lands people in the dark lands are aware
of people in the the Oise Underland
everybody knows about everybody else but
this Shazam family doesn't know any of
this stuff but regardless of the
scenario what you end up having is
basically Billy Batson talking to this
sort of essence who essentially says hey
look in order to help you I need you to
help me I need you to bring me back to
the world of the living and so as soon
as you know as soon as that happens this
other corpse basically pops up and what
this is at least what it looks like is
the original Captain Marvel family from
like back in the day that's kind of how
it looks there's no real indication that
it is aside from like the costumes that
they're wearing but ultimately you know
this this Katharine Marvel seniors
basically like go to the bell tower go
to the bell tower that'll take you where
you need to go and then we kind of
chastises a son right he's like you're
trying to get somebody to bring you back
from the dead one you like that's
exactly what you were trying to do in a
sense like yeah man so that's just kind
of my thing that's what I do but it's
kind of interesting because when this
happens it's really kind of coincides
with Billy Batson's father believing
that Billy doesn't want to see him
believing that Billy doesn't want to
have anything to do with him and so
because that ability really just kind of
goes about his own thing and really kind
of comes across some diner where a
father and son are sharing a milkshake
and just is really sort of fulsome
moment when suddenly Black Adam comes
out of nowhere after basically being
taken by after Savannah now the kind of
deal that was worked out here is a loose
deal
insofar as as dr. sivana and mr. mine
basically tell like Adam so long as you
work
we will not destroy conduct yeah once I
attained absolute power conduct will be
safe and one of the things to understand
about Black Adam if she doesn't care
about anything except for conduct the
world can burn around him but as long as
conduct is fine everything's okay it's
all he cares about as it was kind of a
cool moment because when that happens of
course Billy Batson arrives just in time
to save his father where Black Adam goes
to kill him and then when that happens
he starts to recollect on what he was
told by the wizard at various points in
time your connection to your family is
what makes you strong that's what makes
you hate bull is the ability to expand
this power to other people beside
yourself that's what makes you strong
and that's what keeps Black Adam weak
and because at the end of the day there
are some tasks that we undertake that we
simply cannot undertake on our own and
that's why I'd like Adam fails because
he believes he's the only one that can
do it that he cannot rely on anybody
else and so with that being the case
Billy Batson really kind of harkens that
and then tells his father say the magic
word it's sha Zhi a.m. and then his
father says like Shazam and boom Billy
batts his dad becomes what becomes part
of the Shazam family and can we just say
here the costume looks legit the gold
and the red and the white Lee he looks
he looks like Hulk Hogan but he looks
amazing and his dad starts freaking out
he's like what in the hell is going on
which is exactly what you would expect
and it's kind of funny because when he
looks at Billy he doesn't recognize him
as Billy all he knows him is this
superhero Shazam and so Billy kind of
starts to break it down for him and say
hey look man I'm your son basically I
gave you a fraction of my power
we got a defeat Black Adam we've got to
be able to take this guy out right
because the seven deadly sins we're
essentially handed over to Black Adam by
mr. mine and dr. sivana as use them for
your own ends whatever goal it is that
you want to achieve and then of course a
fight kind of breaks out between these
two guys now at the end of the day with
Mary Marvel showing up remember the
seven deadly sins are very powerful and
while you do have Billy Batson and you
do have Mary Marvel who can kind of hold
their own at the end of the day their
father isn't really familiar with his
powers and in the way that he needs to
be right because he just became the hero
no way he's gonna understand everything
about becoming Shazam basically you're
part of the Shazam family in the span of
like a minute and a half right it's just
not gonna happen and so because of that
the other part of the situation Connie
becomes more complicated when Mary
Marvel's powers start flickering out and
she reverts back to her normal self
dinner powers come back and then Billy's
father reverts back to his normal self
right and so because of this because the
waters
murky and because there's no real clear
instance where they can basically defeat
Black Adam and the seven deadly sins
they bail out and they arrive in the
Oise under Lance and so of course
they're rescued by the Scarecrow from
Alice in Wonderland the munchkins from
from The Wizard of Oz and once they make
it far enough of course they come across
the Cheshire cat now the Cheshire cat of
course is working for the witches at
this point in time which is kind of
interesting to see the Cheshire cat ally
itself in that way
and the original Alice in Wonderland the
Cheshire Cat was kind of a neutral party
he was really more entertained than
anything else and it really seemed to be
the only one aside from like the Gryphon
that really seemed to know what was
going on and was kind of like okay so
like this place is you know I'm like I'm
the only one that's got it all figured
out basically that seemed normal you
know for lack of a better word but with
that being the case of course building
in them basically come to and then the
Cheshire Cat leaves an action is
ultimately sent away by Mayor Marvel but
before it does it essentially says the
war of the magic realms begins now
right the wars the magic Rome starts now
which is kind of cool I mean it's
interesting insofar as is is what's
going on but it's not the most
intriguing right what is intriguing
about this is that you have the wizard
who shows up to Billy and basically says
the reason why the powers between your
father and Mary Marvel are blinking in
and out is because you don't know who
your family is the connection that you
share with the members of your family is
only as strong as the connection you
feel you have with them and so while you
look at Mary and you look at Darla and
you look at Freddy and you look at gene
Eugene you look at Pedro and you see
them as your true family because you
guys have such a strong bond you look at
your father and you don't really see him
as your actual family right like you
have to make a choice which one is it is
it your father and your mother or is it
everybody else right the rest of the
Shazam family and it's kind of nuts he's
like that's why the power keeps
flickering and bouncing around because
your connections just not that strong
this is how the sharing spell has always
worked your connection has to be strong
you cannot share between two different
families and so he's like this is how it
works it's the way it's always worked
you have to make a choice and the
responsibility here is if the living
lightning is mine to use then I will
decide how it gets used I don't care
about your rules your rules are based on
how you use the magic I'm going to make
rules based on how I use the magic and I
choose my father and I choose my
adoptive siblings as my family we are
the Shazam family and then in turn they
all have their powers activated and the
connection is full-on through all of
them it's badass
like dude this full-page splash is legit
dude it's just like is this like Shazam
and Mary and Eugene and Pedro and all of
them is just like yeah
it's pretty awesome and so as a result
of that what we end up finding out here
is you do get a bit of a reprieve in the
sense that you essentially have like
king kid who basically invades earth
more or less who invades like the the
city of Philadelphia it's not the most
important thing ever
and the funny thing about this is Geoff
Johns tells us it's not that important
right he's like it's a distraction is a
distraction created by dr. sivana and
mr. maan to keep Shazam and the Shazam
family occupied so they can continue
doing their thing right it ends in like
four pages where they end up stealing
basically the wishing stick of king Kidd
and all of his stuff vanishes right all
of the soldiers all of his henchmen all
that kind of stuff it all basically goes
away and the result of that is you know
he's essentially handed over to the
wizard Shazam and of course we'll find
out what happens to him in a little whap
the reality is he's basically thrown
back into the into the fun lands and the
adults in the fun lands will decide what
to do with it right that's the fate that
befall him but Jimmy back into the meat
and potatoes of this right the really
really good part of this what you end up
getting here is you in up getting dr.
sivana and you get mr. mind
who make their way into the monster
lands and the monster lands were
basically this section of the of the
magic lands but that were completely
sealed off no one gets in and no one
gets out and so what they end up doing
is coming across this gigantic castle
right that looks pretty dark and it
looks pretty twisted and so when sivanna
and mr. mine get in there mr. mine kind
of explains what's going on in saying
that these are all basically prisoners
of the seven magic lands these these
quote-unquote monsters dared to defy the
Wizards over the millennia is really how
he explains it how he describes it and
what he says is that at one point in
time the rock of eternity was kind of
this Citadel that existed across the
magic lands and it was kind of a
pilgrimage right like people could make
their way there and they could basically
Delvin the various magics were learn how
to become a magician or how to how to
wield these magical powers by basically
going to the the council at the rocky of
eternity and then pleading their case is
saying like this is how this is what I
want to do and they'd be judged yes you
can no you can't that kind of a thing
but what ended up happening is that with
Black Adam doing what he did and
essentially betraying the council did
they became a lot more guarded and so
what they did is they essentially
stripped all the gods across the across
the multiverse of all their magical
energy accorded it all to themselves and
then sealed themselves off on the rock
of eternity from the rest of all
existence so that nobody could usurp
their power and use it to try to conquer
or destroy the multiverse and so as a
result of that they've kind of been
isolated and they've kind of been
removed ever since so that's what mr.
mine is working on here is basically
acquiring
all these different monsters and then
using them for their own purpose but the
big takeaway here the big thing that
happens here
Savannah notices the door and he says
this store is so small compared to all
the others who's in there and mr. mind
says someone that we will not be asking
to join us what we have they do not want
they don't want anything to do with
magic and this person chimes in this kid
inside this room chimes in and says I
can hear you wait until you see what I
do dishes am when I get out here
this kid is incredibly important and the
question is why because he's got a
Superman symbol carved onto his chest
yes my friends this is none other than
superboy-prime what had being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace okay I want to give a shout out to
Kyle B David Joseph then john h aj matt
in Jeff our John H lean and mean which
is an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K
and Genesis 9:6 team remember guys you
could send me messages and I'll run off
whatever your message is at the end of
the video so long as there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]